good morning Hank it's Friday December
3rd as you can possibly tell from the
lamp shaped like a jellyfish I'm not in
my house
instead Hank I'm in Miami with its
beautiful beaches and it's palm trees
and it's fancy art fairs none of which I
get to enjoy because even though I
mentioned earlier that it is December
3rd I still haven't finished math
annoyed games gone national finish a
drop in your book a bit seriously come
on month it's like it's still over bah I
am a giant swagger but Hank I've got to
put aside the Giants would have anger in
my heart because today we have to talk
about giant squids of love but even more
importantly I want to discuss with you
why I'm so fascinated by the sex lives
of species different from us ok Hank so
here is the giant squid majestic very
secretive we don't know what they eat we
don't know how deep they're able to dive
we don't know what they do for fun and
we don't really know for sure how they
mate but we got some ideas and they
involve penile fire hoses all right Hank
so most squid have eight arms to longer
tentacles that they use for feeding and
one heck toka tieless which is kind of
like a penis except that it falls off
every time they have sex like they put
it into the girl squid and then the girl
squid kind of breaks it off but giant
squids don't have a hectic at Eilis
instead they have a three-foot long
penis and like a lot of invertebrates
they produce spermatophores which are
like these sacs that contain sperm but
unfortunately female giant squid Anatomy
doesn't really give you a convenient
place to put that spermatophore and
that's where the fire hose comes in Hank
in the last 48 hours I've read so much
about giant squid sex that I'm surprised
the hotel still lets me have internet
and so I can tell you that without fail
researchers who are hypothesizing about
giant squid sex always refer to the male
squid penis as a fire hose because what
they think happens is the male squids
penis approaches a female squids arm and
then like a fire hose shoots a
spermatophore into the arm
at which point the female as you can
imagine it's like oh why don't you just
don't know man
which is actually bad for the male's
because the females are much larger and
that biologists think is why the male
squid penis is so long so they don't
have to get too close to the females in
order to inseminate them now I'm not an
expert in the field but it seems to me
that fire hosing you're spermatophore
into a lady arm is not a pleasant or
even very efficient method of
production and it makes me wonder why
well I don't they just find a better way
to do it but from an evolutionary
perspective is it ultimately more
helpful to have an efficient mating
system or is it more helpful to have say
an AI that's a foot freakin wide which
is what giant squids have in fact we see
examples over and over in our world
we've been talking about them all week
of incredibly inefficient mating tank
it's almost as if sex is not actually
the most important thing that animals
including humans do and Hank I believe
that is one thing giant squids are
trying to tell us I got to go back to my
story but Hank I will see you on Monday
duh nerdfighters always forgot but
because you proved that space pasta is
far less efficient than Earth beef you
now get to challenge us to do something
difficult and/or horrible I should add
however that a nerdfighter named Stan
egde did some research suggesting that
space pasta might actually be more
efficient than Earth beef if we use the
space shuttle to pick it up instead of
Apollo 11 provided that there was
already space pasta on the moon but
sadly at least as far as we know there
isn't space pasta on the moon at any
rate you figured it out so you get to
challenge us leave your suggestions for
challenges in the comments and upload
your favorites and as always dftba